today i'm excited to unveil to you my
ultimate theory
one untouched by studio interference one
unburdened by the needs of an algorithm
in this
one video i am freed from the shackles
of convention
and can present to you my true artistic
vision
and now for your viewing pleasure my
snyder cut theory
in 360p resolution just as it was always
meant to be watched
this sucks hello internet welcome to
film theory where the four-hour version
of this episode is currently locked in a
vault waiting for warner brothers to
call and offer us 30 million dollars for
reshoots
well while we wait for that call i
wanted to talk about the newly released
snyder cut
version of the 2017 movie justice league
which i will be the first to admit was
way better than i ever expected i mean
take that with a
hefty grain of salt considering it's
like one of the only movies i've seen in
months and the original was real bad but
hey
set the bar low enough and you have
nowhere to go but up that was my motto
in high school
seriously though my bro zack actually
pulled it off and transformed a garbage
fire of a movie both in terms of plot
and
coloring into a real movie with real
characters and real stakes and if you
have no idea what i'm talking about
here's the 30-second catch-up back in
2016 wb and dc were in a rush to catch
up with the massive success marvel was
having with big superhero team-up movies
which you know it's gonna be hard for
them when they had no team
at that point in time they'd only had
one movie man of steel and it wasn't all
that well received
so instead of doing solo projects to
introduce the characters one at a time
they instead tried to do everything all
at once
jumping from here's superman two now
that you know superman here's this guy
who dresses as a bat and wants to punch
him
also wonder woman is here for reasons
and want to see some youtube clips of
these other guys that
may become important at some point also
hallucinations
as you might imagine that movie batman v
superman came out to reviews that
weren't so great but justice league the
immediate sequel
a film that's important to remember was
planned to be a trilogy of movies was
already well into production and set for
release the next year at that point so
a bit late to make any changes there
early test screenings for the first
justice league weren't great and the
studio was already eyeing major reshoots
so
things weren't peachy but they went from
bad to worse when a family tragedy
struck zack snyder and he had to step
down as director getting replaced with
avengers director joss whedon who at the
studio's request tried to change the
tone of the movie to more closely match
dc's more successful rivals
unfortunately the clashing visions of
the two directors made justice league
get at joss whedon's justice league an
awkward final product
prompting a huge fan movement for zack
snyder to have the chance to finish the
movie he
started hbo max decided to grant
everyone's wish giving zach and the team
an enormous 30 million dollar budget for
reshoots and yeah the movie is out now
and objectively it was a success
the rotten tomatoes scores for the
snyder cut are 73
from critics and 95 from fans 95
they jumped right past marvel numbers
and went straight to pixar numbers and i
gotta say regardless of how you feel
about the movie or dc
or all of this drama congratulations to
zack snyder i'm sure it is supremely
satisfying to make the movie he wanted
to make to see it get such a positive
reception but most importantly of all
finally have this chapter come to a
close a movie that
i would guess reminds him of what was
undoubtedly one of the hardest moments
in his life so are the legions of fans
who are campaigning for this
finally satisfied who are you kidding of
course not if you give a mouse a cookie
he'll ask you for a glass of milk you
give him the milk suddenly he's gonna
demand a billion dollar film
franchise this story is no longer about
hashtag release the snyder cut the
hashtag is now
restore the snyderverse which case
you're not familiar means continuing the
darker established storyline that snyder
had in mind for these films
as opposed to you know scrapping it all
as recent news has suggested that the
studio plans to do
and look i know that other online
commentators out there are annoyed by
even more snyder fan outcry but
personally i think it's totally fine
i definitely don't like the fact that
they review bomb other movies to get
their message out there or how
aggressive some of their tactics are but
those are just a few bad eggs in this
group
overall i can't fault people for liking
a series of movies and then dedicating
years of their lives to being fans of
those movies and then being disappointed
when the movies don't reach their proper
conclusion
no one likes an unresolved cliffhanger
that said i'm also here today to tell
those people to save their breath
in fact i'm here to tell them to rejoice
friends spare your tweets the snyder
verse is already restored in fact
it never left no matter what they say
publicly about having no plans to move
forward that's
exactly what they're doing they planned
for this to happen but i'm not talking
about this just from a sneaky business
perspective the proof is actually
in the new snyder cut of justice league
you heard me right the snyder cut
version of justice league is
actually canon to the established dc eu
in fact
not only is it canonical it serves as
the good ending to the complete snyder
vs story so today i want to put the
issue to rest because in my mind both
the theatrical cut and the snyder cut
can fit into the larger dc
eu if and only if wb and dc
have the cojones to do it so first
things first it's important to
understand that coming up on dc's future
release schedule is a flash solo movie
see it's been established for a while
now that this movie will be inspired by
the flashpoint storyline in the comics
in which barry allen the flash goes back
in time to save his mother from being
murdered by his arch nemesis
the reverse flash now not to go on too
much of a tangent here but john broome
the dc writer who created
the reverse flash he must have just
phoned this one in hard
just imagine his manager bursting into
his office one day like we need a bad
guy for the flash and jon was like uh
reverse flash he's just like the flash
but yellow where red should be and red
where yellow should be
anyway by saving his mother barry
accidentally alters reality in some
major ways but only he can notice for
everyone else things have just always
been this different way
dc also took the opportunity to use the
flashpoint event in the comics to make
some
major changes and fix their continuity
clearing away the unpopular characters
and storylines to make room for the
things that audiences liked hmm
now why does this all sound like the
perfect thing for dc to do at this point
in time with their movies could it have
anything to do with the fact that as of
right now they have four completely
disconnected projects all
featuring batman joker snyder's justice
league
justice league and robert pattinson's
batman
that's not confusing and bloated at all
or maybe it's the fact that according to
wonder woman director patty jenkins even
the movie directors at this point are
ignoring the wedon
era version of justice league despite wb
still holding firm that that
is the canonical timeline i mean i could
go on with more reasons why this
franchise might need a universal reset
at this point but i think you get it and
while i say it's a solo movie
it's really shaping up to be a
multiverse movie akin to into the
spiderverse during last year's dc
fandom event which it's worth noting had
100 hours of streaming content about
their upcoming projects available for
get this one day 24 hours so i hope
you're watching everything at three
times speed
not a great plan the team working on the
new flash movie revealed the fact that
not just one but
two batman would be appearing in it both
ben affleck's batman from the current
gen of movies as well as michael keaton
who played batman and tim burton's
original 1989 blockbuster
this strongly indicates that flashpoint
will be dealing not just with time
travel but with dc's multiverse it's the
exact thing that snyder's new movie
already is heavily alluding to the
anti-life equation
the key to controlling all life and all
will
throughout the multiverse and i think
you can start to see where i'm going
with this
of course the snyder versus canon
whether explicitly or not when
practically everything is going to be
validated in this upcoming multiverse
movie that's how you have two different
justice leagues both canon at the same
time
but you know multiverses are the easy
way out i actually want to take it one
step further i want to show you that
snyder's new timeline is
actually one in the same with the
original and established dc continuity
it is canonical
with the justice league movie they're
all a continuation of the exact
same story the snyder cut is the good
ending to our adventure let me explain
you see when you have nearly twice as
much movie to fill you can do things
like fill it with icelandic
song breaks and an egregious amount of
moody staring but in that extra amount
of time you can also make some pretty
radical alterations to a movie's
original story including prophecies and
extended epilogues set in the ruined
wastelands of earth devastated by the
attacks of dark side and evil superman
this is the nightmare future that's a
knight with a k
get it as in the dark knight anyway in
this thing we see wonder woman dead
aquaman dead flash is a hardened warrior
and batman teaming up with the joker
so what where's all this coming from
well
this was always meant to be a core
element in zack snyder's justice league
trilogy back when it was supposed to be
a three movie series in snyder's
original vision for justice league 2
which he's been very public about
superman would give bruce wayne the job
of protecting lois
lois and bruce would begin to have a
love affair which is
a choice certainly and one that
apparently was rejected by the studio so
at least they showed some good judgment
there anyway during a crucial moment
bruce would hesitate
resulting in lois's death and superman
turning to the dark
side brought on by darkseid in justice
league three batman and the remaining
team would build a device
the cosmic treadmill which would allow
flash to travel back to the past
warn bruce about darkseid and stress the
importance of saving lois's life thereby
changing the future and we see that this
nightmare future
does come true in visions throughout the
snyder cut we see superman cradling a
burnt body
presumably lois inside of the bat cave
as evidenced by the robin suit hidden in
the back
the nightmare is real we actually hear
it from the joker himself
you need me to help you undo this world
you created by letting her
die how many alternate timelines do you
destroy the world because
you don't have the colonies to dye
yourself the question though
is in what universe is the dark
nightmare future
happening well i firmly believe based on
the evidence in all these movies that
the nightmare
is the result of joss whedon's justice
league dark side come to earth
superman turning evil it's all the
continuation of
justice league and what the canon dc eu
is headed towards
when the flash loops back and goes to
war in the past
that sets up the snyder stories batman v
superman
and his version of justice league those
create a second timeline the one that
does
things right and actually manages to
save the earth but how can we be sure
about this well in the original cut of
justice league bruce wayne has no
idea about lois lane being the key to
anything he doesn't comment on his
prophecies he doesn't mention his dreams
he doesn't mention lois lane at
all compare that to the snyder cut where
he actively talks about his dreams with
diana i had a dream
barry allen was right here and he said
to me
lois lane is the key this is a reference
to the flash's warning in batman v
superman
which is clearly happening on the second
timeline
after these events have already
transpired once because he wasn't warned
batman in justice league only thinks of
lois as the woman in a relationship with
superman nothing special to take note of
it would make sense that this version of
batman would drop the ball
on protecting her or as the joker says
why you sent a boy wonder
to do a man's job but in the snyder cut
bruce is
keenly aware of lois outright commenting
on her being pregnant with superman's
baby
congratulations by the way and it's all
because of the warning that he received
from the future
in addition the first version of justice
league shows us a much more fragmented
team
even as he goes out into the last battle
batman just barks out the order
don't wait for me just do the job when
he gets saved by the rest of the league
cyborg indicates that it wasn't a team
decision hey blame the lady
we would have left you but she didn't
ask for a vote this indicates that the
mainline dc
eu justice league isn't going to be as
tightly knit
as the snyder lying justice league which
is why we see them fighting and
dying to dark side solo in the nightmare
hallucinations further proof of this
comes from the joker references
throughout the nightmare in the snyder
cuts epilogue we see joker give bruce a
truce card
as long as you have this card the truce
but all you have to do is tear them up
and i'm happy to discuss with you in any
way like why you sent a boy wonder to do
a man's job
it's a symbol of them putting aside
their differences to be a team and in
batman v
superman we actually see bruce with that
card
taped to his gun however in the scene of
superman lording over the fallen remains
of the heroes we see the joker's card
torn batman broke the truce a weak team
ultimately leads to the destruction of
humanity mostly driven by batman's ego
meanwhile the snyder cut shows us a team
that cares much more about each other
with barry specifically caring a lot
about bruce wayne
are you okay
there's also smaller details here too
like how in the nightmare visions
aquaman is killed by a three-pronged
trident
that's the trident of atlan the one that
we see him accept in the aquaman movie
which is a canonical continuation of
joss whedon's justice league and we know
it based on a few details
first the events of both films in the
snyder cut mira's parents are explicitly
stated as being dead
my parents died in the wars however in
the aquaman movie her father plays a
significant
role in the events that transpire
additionally we have ourselves mira's
accent here is how mira talks in aquaman
your half-brother king orm is about to
declare warp on the surface world
billions will die here's how she sounds
in the original
justice league it would have been her
responsibility to follow that monster to
the surface and stop it
now it's yours
and here's her completely different
accent from the snyder cut
it would have been her responsibility to
follow that monster to the surface and
stop him
now it's yours
there's also the flash in justice league
barry has no confidence
in fact he outright says that he's never
done battle before full transparency
i've never done battle
i've just pushed some people and run
away his whole arc in that entire story
is that he needs to save just
one person save one what
save one person compare that to the
snyder cut where barry is not only
saving people
and hot dogs on the regular but already
knows how to use his extreme
speed to manipulate time to such a
degree that he can catch the exact
moment a mother box hits the water in
batman v superman we see a berry who's
trying to travel through time but
misses his target date
that would make sense if it was the
first time that he was testing out time
travel powers pushing his limits only
because of a severe need for survival
but the snyder cuts flash is
honed in his time travel skills which
also makes sense
if this is the second go-around for this
universe but the biggest detail that
confirms all of this is the fact that in
the justice league no one knows who
darkseid is
unlike the snyder cut which ends with
the team facing him down and martian
manhunter issuing a warning to bruce
justice league has nothing the team has
no frame of reference that steppenwolf
works for an even bigger bad
as such they won't be preparing for this
massive alien invasion and without
batman's investment into lois lane's
well-being
darkseid will have little problem
killing her turning superman evil
this darkest timeline will lead barry
allen to hop on the cosmic treadmill and
try to go back in time to alert batman
and create the alternate
snyder line where they actually have a
chance to save the universe
in short the nightmare epilogue created
by zack snyder in his movie is dunking
on the original cut
basically calling it the failed ending
of his storyline
this is what happens to the characters
whose stories continue on
they die they fail the team falls apart
this in turn sets up the snyder cut to
not only be canon but also be the good
conclusion
of everything that came before
correcting the mistakes that were made
in the past which
come to think of it is insanely meta
considering that's how these movies
themselves shaped up to be
the long and short of it is this dc
listen to me sit down
on the couch and actually listen to me
because sometimes you don't know what's
good for you
you have yourselves a real shot here to
please fans without totally backtracking
on all your movies
you have yourself a win here served up
on a silver platter
don't blow it because not even
flashpoint will be able to erase
another misstep like that but hey that's
just a theory a film theory
and cut
you